so every time I press the go live button
on YouTube after about five seconds
YouTube has this really annoying pop-up
over the screen where it's like why
don't you inject an ad right now right
when you're going live right when
everyone is waiting for you to start the
show every day every time I just want to
make sure you all know that because how
stupid would it be for me to be like
welcome to the show and then all's at an
ad place and that's apparently what they
want me to do so uh no YouTube anyway
today was uh there's a lot of crazy news
in Tennessee they've expelled at least
one Democrat so far voted not to expel
another and these are because these
Democrats engaged in Insurrection and
there's videos it's crazy so basically
you've got these uh these Democrats who
joined the protest at the Capitol in
Tennessee where there was actually
violence against cops and lawmakers and
now they're voting to expel them so I
think so far one is is not being
expelled one has been expelled and this
guy's a history of assaulting members of
of the Tennessee legislature already
we're gonna talk about that plus we're
getting rumors that conservative
District Attorneys are contacting GOP
reps to uh figure out how to indict Joe
Biden because well the doors have been
opened and this is where we're going and
then we've got a whole bunch of other
crazy news there was another uh um mass
shooting was was thwarted by law
enforcement this is a trans individual
head of Manifesto the post millennial
has the story we have Rebecca Jones out
of Florida turned in her own son because
he was threatening to commit a a master
this is crazy and she's a Democratic
candidate very much hates DeSantis and
then of course we have the
Anheuser-Busch controversy so a lot to
go through Travis uh was it Travis Tritt
is that his name yeah and uh Kid Rock
and I think John rich and a whole bunch
of other artists apparently are dropping
all Anheuser-Busch products the rumors
are that internally Anheuser-Busch is
freaking out because of the backlash so
um well good I think everybody should
boycott all Anheuser-Busch products not
just because Bud Light is garbage
but alcohol is bad for you so you know
there you go and Jack Daniel's
apparently too so we'll get into all
that before we do my friends today's
episode is sponsored by our very own
cast brew coffee
cast Brew is our coffee brand it is
officially in pre-order we have two
signature coffee roasts available it
will ship by May 5th Roberto Jr is the
mascot so of course pick up your rise
with Roberto Jr breakfast Blend or your
Appalachian nights robust dark blend
today to help support the show we are
sponsoring ourselves we're going to
start branching out building new
companies because we want to make we
want to we want we want to control
companies we want to make companies that
do the right thing that believe in
America that aren't going to back down
that aren't going to I don't know
complain about some young kid who
happens to be wearing a shirt for your
coffee company and then be like we have
nothing to do with that kid like we
don't do anything like that we want to
be outright just like good people
selling a good cup of coffee and a bunch
of other stuff too so we have a cafe
currently under construction which
hopefully will be open in a few months
in West Virginia I'm really excited for
this also don't forget to go to
timcast.com click that join us button
and then become a member
support our work directly and you'll get
access to tonight's members only
uncensored live show at about 10 10 p.m
and if you do sign up you can join the
Discord where if you sign up for at
least 25 or you've been a member for at
least six months you can submit
questions and maybe even call into the
show and talk to us as part of the show
it's my favorite part of the night to be
completely honest because it brings more
and more people in so um become a member
of support I work smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
if you really do like it joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Tom fitton
good to be with you thanks for having me
again absolutely who are you what do you
do I'm president Judicial Watch which is
America's largest most effective
government Watchdog group we sue the
government to get access information we
sue the government when it breaks the
law
and we represent whistleblowers and
other victim and victims of government
oppression and abuse that all sounds
like really good stuff it is it's great
it's great to be happy to go to work
every day right on cool man well we got
a lot to talk about especially with what
they're doing to Trump so should be
interesting he's a he's a crime victim
that's for sure absolutely and of course
Hannah Claire brimelow is hanging out hi
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com hello everyone Ian
Crossland here happy to be back good to
see you
at iamsurge.com I'm ready to roll when
you are Tim let's get it so we have this
first story from everyone's favorite
state-funded or what what Twitter call
it State Affiliated Affiliated media NPR
Tennessee house votes not to expel a
second Democratic member over gun
protest so I chose uh NPR just because I
love how they're gonna smooth out the
language here anti-gun protest is that
that's right yes what was what was the
January 6 how was that then that was
just a uh a peaceful uh parade peaceful
parade yeah all right they say after
voting party even costume that's right
that's right you know councilman after
voting I mean the police escorts for
people in costume after voting to expel
a Tennessee State Rep for leading a
raucous protest a protest on from the
house floor calling for gun law reform
the republican-led body declined to
expel a second member in the 65 to 30
vote lawmakers failed to pass a motion
that would remove rep Gloria Johnson who
represents about 70 000 tennesseans in
Knoxville cheers erupted blah blah blah
three make three lawmakers acknowledge
they didn't follow the rules of order or
decorum and decorum by speaking out
without being formally recognized but
they're facing a disciplinary measure
it's only been used twice since the
1800s gee I wonder why it is that
they're going after uh these these here
protesters could it be um is it this
story I have right here here we go from
2019 activist Justin Jones banned from
Capital after alleged assault on speaker
Glenn Casada oh
so it was an insurrection but I'm just
gonna I'm gonna skip over the
pleasantries and I'm gonna skip right to
the part where I talk about Civil War
and I'll explain it this way
a few years ago an individual was I
believe arrested I want to make sure I
get that right I believe I believe it
was a ban from the capital
and uh let's see blah blah Justin Jones
23 was charged with two counts of
misdemeanor assault and one counter
disorderly conduct after authorities say
he threw a cup of coffee into an
elevator striking Casada and rep Deborah
Moody a republican from Covington Jones
Vanderbilt student and more than a dozen
other protesters assembled outside the
house chamber on Thursday to protest to
the bust of Nathan Bedford Forrest a
confederate general
so this is 2019. he actually attacked
attacked members of the legislature and
then a few years later he's in it
so you know I wouldn't call throwing
coffee at someone like a caning or
anything like that but what I think
we're continually seeing with this with
the indictment of Donald Trump and where
everything is going is that the
bifurcation of American culture is now
within the confines of our state and
federal governments to the point where
you actually have a person who
physically attacked Republicans in
office I mean you'd think that would
have been news in the first place it's
like hey remember that guy who attacked
the the legislature he got elected he's
here now well now he's being thrown out
again he's being expelled and their
pledge they're saying you can't keep him
out he will be back I can only imagine
that as we see more of this at the state
level combined with the false charges
against Donald Trump we are heading
towards whatever you want to call it
this country being split in half
well you know it's it's once I would I
would consider it to be one part of the
country has decided just to leave in
terms of refusing to follow the basic
principles I call it the American way
that we have this Rising communism
within the Democratic party they reject
what we all have believed in or you know
we we Americans have commonly approved
of which is the rule of law
uh you know we have a republican form of
government we don't vote by mob rule
which is what they try to do in
Tennessee you know another basic respect
for civil liberties and civil rights and
and the Communists don't believe in any
of that they're rejecting it so you know
they'll try to overturn A legislature in
Tennessee they'll try to attack the
Supreme Court here in Washington D.C
they try to jail their their political
opponents in the form of Donald Trump we
see this now with the January 6th grand
jury investigations where they're trying
to jail people for exercising their
first amendment rights on the state
federal constitutional law to dispute an
election so you know that they're
they're kind of throwing out the window
all the sort of norms that we used to
well believe in it's so I mean the
divorce is they're abandoning the family
or even better even worse trying to
destroy it they believe might makes
right that well it's it's the Communist
it's you know they can call themselves
whatever they want com you know they're
not going to call themselves Communists
Communists well a lot of them actually
do right
but uh you know this this is the left
this is the the totalitarian impulse of
the left and it's been unhinged and I've
been observing politics for longer than
I care to admit to rarely would I say
something is communist but you know
we're facing this communist
revolutionary moment over the last two
years three years and uh I don't know
we're we're an Undiscovered Country when
it comes to that you know my favorite
part of this is we have the story from
the Daily Mail Biden blasts shocking and
undemocratic Tennessee House of
Representatives for vote to expel one of
three Democratic lawmakers so uh if you
as a lawmaker join a violent call it a
riot because they were fighting with
cops and they were actually blocking a
legislator in the bathroom and he had to
be like hugging police officers as they
try and pull them through an Angry Crowd
screaming and yelling Biden calls it
undemocratic to remove the people who
did that right so what would you call
January 6th what would you call your
justice department government trying to
jail your predecessor
for a speech where he told people to go
peaceably protest about the election
so Biden is approving of an Insurrection
in Tennessee while trying to jail Trump
on protectual charges for inciting
violence in Washington D.C and the
problem is I see that conservatives keep
trying to argue with the left about why
they're right and it's like bro they
don't care yeah
I mean if you look at the news coverage
of the Tennessee event I mean USA Today
put out this huge like the coverage of
what happened at Tennessee is completely
wrong don't believe any of it these
right-wing commentators are crazy
they're perpetrating rumors even uh with
uh Justin Jones in the chamber they're
saying oh it's an impromptu protest they
didn't plan it at all it's just that
they had supporters in the balcony and
they strategically knew when to get up
and start protesting on the floor I mean
they are telling you one story not to
win conservatives over but to completely
solidify their base I'm not trying to
I'm not saying they're trying to win
conservatives over of course they aren't
I'm saying conservatives are trying to
win them over and they're pretending
like it's possible or for some Maybe
even that for some reason there are
conservatives who think that facts care
about feelings that like that Ben
Shapiro standing up and speaking at
University is going to convince people
some but very few right this show the
the the work you do you go to these
people and show them evidence and
they'll go oh wow and then what they'll
do is they'll take the information and
they'll be like they're on to us we got
to adjust our strategy and and try and
find a different way to exploit and gain
power yeah well you know I I would
suggest that the way to think about what
Ben does what we're all doing really is
we're we're trying to educate the
American people and showing leadership
for those of us who are concerned about
these issues the left as you point out
isn't going to be convinced but we got
to speak out and provide leadership and
the truth and let people know there are
people who know what's going on and this
is the way forward but I get that I'm
saying there are people arguing with a
leftist oh yes yeah well there are no
standards I mean the big question I've
been asked about on the news recently
with the Trump thing is what about the
double standards as if they care about
double standards there's one standard
jail them and protect us the ones as far
as the left is going I mean they're
being perfectly consistent which is no
rules we go after you and there's
nothing you can do about it right and
then where it's it's what we're talking
about Dave Smith the uh the Republicans
are the Washington generals and the
Democrats of the Globetrotters that's
that's been analogy for several years
now the Democrats pretend like
Republicans are running circles around
them when the Republicans do literally
nothing
and then the Democrats steamroll
everything quite literally indicting
Donald Trump on nothing and two
impeachments two impeachments over
nothing and they're still nervous about
impeaching one of his cabinet officials
who who is partly responsible for uh the
most significant human trafficking
operation in the history of man uh the
the crisis at the southern border uh I
start talking about Biden impeachment
people get very nervous in Washington
D.C let's have an inquiry into what
Biden's done I mean we had news two
weeks not even two weeks ago well I mean
you know that further confirming that
millions of dollars were laundered
through the Biden family Enterprises
from the Chinese Communists has there
been any leadership from the house on
pursuing impeachment for that it doesn't
mean they're not doing some good
investigative work here but to me
there's this urgency and there's this
crisis related to the rule of law our
Republic is tottering it is tottering
and we need leaders that recognizes the
recognize the problem and respond with
the appropriate urgency I I think we're
past that point I mean
I with what's happening in Tennessee
with what's happening with Trump I mean
and as especially with Trump but I think
it's important to point out Tennessee
shows the more Grassroots level of
things the state level the local level
it's happening there the bifurcation
Donald Trump is the first president
former president to be indicted and the
charges are completely bunk right even
even Chris Hayes on MSNBC is like yeah
there's nothing here I mean the statute
of limitations is up what is this
they're doing it anyway because they
don't care they are they're they're
making their moves in slow gradual ways
that are difficult to defend against and
Donald Trump in my opinion should not
have surrendered he should have said
file the paperwork let me know and then
when the media came out and said there's
two things they would have gained by
this the media came out and said this
indictment is bunk Trump would have been
like well I don't know what's going I
mean MSNBC said it was there was nothing
here so what am I supposed to do he
could use them and if they do want to
pursue it knowing there's no underlying
crime so this edge of the limitations is
up they would have to contact Ron
DeSantis Administration for extradition
and if DeSantis did extradite Trump he
would be out of the jupy primary like
that Trump would completely just knock
him out and have nothing to worry about
but that his head is probably wouldn't
do anything and knowing that what would
end up happening is Trump would be
sitting in his home he'd say I don't
know anything about this they're free to
file whatever legal paperwork they want
and and we'll read it and then when
Bragg fails to get any support from the
cultural left fails to get an
extradition he'd be sitting there
confused saying what do I do no one's
going to be like only the weirdos on
Twitter are going to be calling for
escalation so Trump would have just been
like I don't know what happened to that
thing well the weirdos on Twitter seem
to be running
our establishment these days I mean
Bragg
but his extremist approach here uh with
the help of Lanny Davis an old Clinton
lawyer who's representing Michael Cohen
that lawyer he brought in from the Biden
Administration was a longtime Obama hand
and these other leftists and you know
the the Soros approach to uh governance
which is to abuse the justice system to
Target your political entities and uh
you know that's straight out of the
Twitter sphere that sort of crazy
anti-trumpism and it's so it's so
dangerous and and I say there's like
this storm front all across the Eastern
Seaboard from Georgia Fulton County sane
crowd uh same species allegations trying
to abuse Trump for disputing an election
up here in Washington D.C with with
Biden and his justice department
targeting and harassing Trump and up in
New York I tell you
um I I think he's going to get indicted
in multiple jurisdictions and yeah and I
tell you uh Republicans have got to
understand that this is a crisis that
deserves
urgent attention they should be cutting
off funding to the justice department as
appropriate to curtail these abusive
investigations defund New York more or
less defund Fulton County Georgia more
or less
every Power available to them under law
should be used to make sure that Trump
isn't kept as a political prisoner check
out this story we got from the New York
Post at least two Republican District
Attorneys want to prosecute bidens
according to rep James Comer I mean
that's it he says I had two calls
yesterday one from a county attorney in
Kentucky one from Tennessee they were
they were Republican obviously both
states are heavily Republican they want
to know if there are ways they can go
after the bidens now bring it on just
unleash it yeah every single person who
lives in a conservative District should
be contacting your local prosecutor's
office and saying to them I want you to
indict Barack Obama Joe Biden Hillary
Clinton or all three you pick oh boy
should we go through Tom you want to
throw out any random examples of what we
could possibly indict any one of those
three for well I know one of the
brothers for Biden is uh or had been
living in Florida
oh you got Ron DeSantis right there come
on baby yeah you know and well so so I
talked to the New York Post over the
weekend I said all bets are off you're
going to have district attorneys in
Texas and Florida if they're not doing
if they're doing their job they're going
to be thinking what is the hook into the
Biden crime family all right all right
my big thing is I want to see Barack
Obama criminally charged for murder for
the killing of Abdul Rahman al-alaki the
16 year old at the civilian Cafe that
was blown up now Dave Smith mentioned
they'd have to arrest Trump and Bush and
Biden and Clinton and you know and go
back to Bush again for if they're if
they're going after war crimes and
things like that and I'm like well okay
and he agrees but let's let's wind
things back right let's let's go Tit for
Tat they indict Trump on complete bunk
BS
is there anything you've seen in in what
you do that you think is immediately
indictable for the Biden family
oh sure I mean I've interviewed uh Rudy
Giuliani who's a national expert on Rico
uh what you're seeing are the Hallmarks
of a RICO operation and with Biden
running it out of the vice presidency
continuing to benefit from it afterwards
for those that don't know can you break
down Rico well the racketeering
influence corrupt organizations act it's
usually used against the mafia where
family is run and you're kind of engaged
and uh so you're saying 10 for the big
guy big guy right and uh for instance
when Hunter is complaining that I'm
giving money that I'm earning to Joe
and paying all of his bills and Joe
isn't reporting that I mean that's like
something out of Sopranos right yeah you
know we got to take care of you know the
uncle a parody of The Sopranos yeah well
and and it to me it's so wildly
dangerous because it's a national
security threat I mean we're we're we've
got this Civil War uh mentality here in
the United States these days
unfortunately
but think of your Putin you're thinking
of your chairman of Z looking what's
going on here first of all you know
Biden's on the take
because he's in your back pocket you
have Bobby linski saying he is yeah
you've got the Moscow mayor's uh Widow
oligarch giving money to the Biden
family barisma was a Russian leading
company by the way so they've got that
Ukraine angle and then the Chinese what
I mean 35 million dollars last I check
and money going so they've got him on
the take so does it mean that oh I uh
Biden is is is taking a call from Judy
saying what should I do no but when
you're doing their calculus is how is
the U.S going to react well we do know
Biden's corrupt and he knows we know
he's corrupt because we've got the goods
on him so we're going to do things in a
more aggressive way than we might
otherwise like invade Ukraine or put
extra pressure on Taiwan or send a
spycraft to attack the United States and
do figure eights over our military and
watch him do nothing because we got his
number
because of our corrupt dealings with
them it's what they they claimed Donald
Trump was compromised by Russia or worse
a Soviet asset and and the funny thing
is Russia didn't invade Ukraine while
Trump was president
Russia if they did have compromat on
Donald Trump would have been like what's
he gonna do about it but they didn't
instead when Joe Biden gets in they do
and Biden's is like oh I better just
funnel a whole bunch of money into this
country
I think they know
in this instance it's more about Joe
Biden lacks the wherewithal to actually
lead this country the people around him
also don't have the wherewithal
Afghanistan was a complete disaster and
more importantly that was Trump's fault
are they going to indict him for that
after today yeah they've got the they've
got DC the fed's going after Trump
Georgia they're gonna I think they're
gonna go after Trump on a bunch of
different charges and I think
if I had to make a bet he's going to get
convicted in New York and everyone well
that wouldn't surprise me either and I I
would say every active Republican and
every active conservative and dissident
liberals out there should be worried
about their personal Liberty all bets
are off there's nothing too Petty you've
got these uh political prosecutions all
across the United States
uh you know this this poor guy who got
caught up with the uh immigrant or the
illegal alien on his property right him
uh also this guy who ran into a crowd of
protesters he thought his life was on
the line they're Prosecuting him which
one was that uh this is just in the
paper recently I think cernovich had a
tweet on and I retweeted it do you know
where it was
um I'll check my Twitter let me let me
pull up but keep talking and and then
you had the pro-lifers who were being
targeted by the Biden Administration and
then the January 6 protesters where
they're not just focused on protesters
who beat up a cop or hit a cop over the
head they're going after protesters who
committed misdemeanors by being in a
part of the federal property they
weren't supposed to be parading that's
never been prosecuted this way
so it and what's the basis for I mean
what's the distinction well they're just
Republicans and conservatives I was
there for the Kavanaugh hearings Justice
Kavanaugh I mean I saw I mean it's just
like Tennessee I mean it was violent
people were afraid the left was
intimidating and disrupting proceedings
and they got 50 tickets
so I mean we we've got this uh this
effort where the left and its leadership
in the Democratic party too often
endorse violence now I I don't know any
any I don't know any Republicans out
there in a leadership position
that endorse condone and ratify violence
to you I don't no so I I do know it's
endemic in the left I I do think I have
the story you may have referenced is it
is it this one Daniel Perry is 9-1-1
call played in court
is this the guy who he rolls into a car
into a crowd ended up having to kill
someone I don't think he he uh I think
he quote I made a wrong turn a guy
pointed a freaking weapon weapon at me
and I panicked I don't know what to do
I'm just an Uber driver I made a wrong
turn I've never had to shoot someone
before they started shooting back at me
and I got out of the area I'm scared I'm
terrified I'm worried they're going to
go after me I've never had to defend
myself before
they're charging this guy isn't it yep
yep yep and he's accused of murder this
guy they went up to his car just a
regular old Uber driver with what did he
have he had an AK didn't he I don't know
the nature of the weapon he had yeah I'm
sorry man I I said this five years ago I
said you the regular citizen keep
thinking that you will keep your door
closed and keep your lights off and you
will cross your fingers the mob walks
past your home they won't and when they
do fire bomb it and you call 91 and say
For the Love of All That is Holy please
save me they will show up to your house
walk into your house and arrest you for
insulting the mob because two cops can't
deal with a riot but they can deal with
you and if the rioters are screaming and
threatening violence the cops are going
to say well if we don't arrest him
they're going to fire bomb buildings we
may as well just arrest him we saw this
with Dan Dix who is a reporter in Canada
a bunch of far left to start threatening
him and the cops grabbed him and said if
you don't leave we'll arrest you and
he's like what they attacked me and
they're like shut up and leave or you're
under arrest this is only going to get
worse this guy's mind you're an Uber
driver I want you to I want everyone to
understand this you're driving home from
the grocery store you picked up your
milk your bread and your eggs all of a
sudden a violent mob of mask wearing
individuals with weapons surround your
car bang on it and one guy points a gun
at your face
you defend yourself
now you're in prison attempted murder
and the far left extremists
they're letting out the real criminals
and this wasn't wasn't this in the gulag
archipelago
they're writing about with the criminal
when the criminals caught with a weapon
well it's it's it's a mistake they're
just they don't know better it's in
their nature so we'll take weapon from
them and say no no you don't do that
again but if you you understand why you
had the weapon you're good you're going
to the gulag right right well and and
you it kind of goes back to the
Rittenhouse prosecution which was
obvious self-defense but you had
politicized prosecutors up there trying
to make an example of him for exercising
not as just his constitutional right to
defend yourself but your god-given right
to defend yourself I mean this is we
have to recognize these rights that the
left says argue about whether you know
whether the Constitution covers them or
not no the Constitution recognizes these
rights that we had prior to the
Constitution and codifies them and that
goes to the Second Amendment right and
the 14th Amendment which is also caught
caught up with the Second Amendment
people think it's just the Second
Amendment the 14th Amendment equal
protection of the law
and that's not something we're all being
provided right now Trump is having his
civil rights violated six ways to Sunday
equal protection of laws anyone think
that Trump has given the equal
protection of the law with them coming
up with laws that have never been
enforced before or applied in such an
outrageous way against him simply
because of his politics
the terrible times terrible times the
country is uh
I mean
we're in a fifth generational Civil War
and uh I don't know how you can look at
what's going on and think anything else
it is not as the the American Civil War
went with one state being like I have is
a seed another state being like Oh no
you don't no it's various factions of
influence gaining control and what we
have seen consistently over the past
decade is the weaponization of the
office of law to crush
anti-establishment and conservative
individuals and it is escalating and
getting worse every day
when I said this stuff five years ago we
weren't looking at a dude about to go to
prison because black lives matter
pointed a rifle at his face and he's the
bad guy
if you're the victim and you fight back
you go to jail just like that guy in New
York and you know what I think I think
these DA's know they're doing it you
can't have a story like this this Daniel
Perry guy
high profile it's been several years you
can have a story like that and then get
the story out of New York where the uh
what was the parking garage attendant
gets shot twice right wrestles The Gun
away he doesn't have a gun he wrestles a
gun away from the guy who's trying to
kill him shoots him and he wakes up
handcuffed to a hospital bed being
charged with attempted murder
Bragg knew what he was doing they want
you to know if you dare fight back
against the crime they've created they
will punish you that's right and every
police officer in the nation already
knows that which is why uh there's been
more restrictive policing uh less
policing less aggressive policing
because they know if they get in the
wrong situation and they have to defend
themselves or get into a situation where
it's disputed uh their use of force
their lives are over so why would you
voluntarily put yourselves in situations
apparel like that and as a result laws
go unenforced and the bad guys win and I
don't mean ideologically the bad guys
they do win because they support
Insurrection and crime because it helps
build the revolution but the bad guys
who who victimize cities in the criminal
traditional sense are are running
rampant right now in Washington DC every
major city
crime crime is is is
impairing significantly uh people's
right to live safely we just said that
story about
um that guy what do they call him crazy
Bob I think is his nickname was yeah
founder co-founder of cash app and
square yep he leaves San Francisco
because of how bad it's getting and
moves to Miami
goes back to SF for a business trip
2 30 in the morning murdered in the
street
was it in the morning I thought it was
the middle of the afternoon was it I
thought it was 2 30 a.m it wasn't
anything yeah and yet the scary thing is
he took two two two stabs to the chest
and then apparently there's surveillance
footage showing him holding his chest
walking around begging for help and he
goes to a car and lifts his shirt up and
begs for help before dropping dead he
called 9-1-1 and was like begging for
help you know what you know what what
worries me about this is I'm wondering
if he if he died because they he
punctured his lungs and he didn't know
how to protect himself from a chest
sucking list yeah yeah I don't well how
many people would I mean I'm not going
to pretend to be an EMT or anything but
it's not like you have plastic wrap or
anything but my understanding is you can
just Jam your fingers and create a
vacuum to keep yourself breathing I
don't know I'm not gonna pretend to know
I'm just saying
and you never know how you react in that
scenario well I mean well you know who
who and and I'm not and I'm not making
fun of your point but what sort of
insanity that we would talk seriously
about having Mass training wow
I'm from I'm from Chicago so like when I
was a kid I was told what to do if
someone's suffering a chest sucking
wound and they they explain to us you
take a piece of plastic wrap or any kind
of plastic and you tape it down on three
sides to create a vent so when someone
inhales it actually closes the cavity
and forces air out of the wound so they
can keep breathing yeah and then I don't
know it's like a diaphragm of some type
yeah I don't know if jamming your finger
in the wound to create a seal would work
as well but to keep you alive
temporarily because when you get a CH
when you puncture a lung when you inhale
air doesn't actually move in or out so
you're not getting air and you don't
know it feels like you're breathing but
nothing's actually happening and then
you die so I I hope that's not the case
but anyway I digress this is what's
happening in our cities friends
I doubt there will be any justice there
and my understanding is this guy was was
wealthy and Powerful right he wasn't he
was a tech bro he was a tech Mogul guy
founder of square squares worth a lot of
money and cash app yeah yeah he knew
stabbed outside his like luxury
apartment building right yeah yeah I
mean it was it was in the middle of a it
wasn't like a tough area of San
Francisco was it I think all of San
Francisco is a tough area now no that is
yeah it's crazy and uh so there was
another story
I don't know much about it but uh I was
talking about the other day because I'm
hanging out at the poker tables at
Maryland Live casino and the guy on my
left told me his buddy starts talking
about politics someone mentions like
money someone mentions the economy he
says Ah Joe Biden gets mad and then he
mentions a buddy of his in 2020 was
driving with this girl in a pickup truck
when they get surrounded by BLM who are
banging on his car
so he hits the gas runs some people over
they chase him down he calls 9-1-1 he
just got convicted of attempted murder I
don't know the full details of the story
I looked at the guy's name there's no
news coverage of this and it got me
thinking
we've seen stories like Daniel Perry's
where he's an Uber driver confused right
we saw the story out of Provo Utah where
a guy's driving his truck BLM runs up
and just shoots the guy for no reason
shoots a guy I think shot a guy in the
arm I bet it might have been a woman
how many of those stories have also
happened where there was no video
footage and so we've not heard anything
so when I looked up this story of this
guy what did I find the media just says
he ran over a bicyclist that's it
there's nothing else because there's no
footage showing black lives matter
antifa trying to kill him or his
girlfriend
and on top of that we have this uh
this kind of craziness with the
transgender extremism which is
obviously a violent movement uh it's a
tool of the left of course
they just arrested uh someone else
seemingly well let me let me let me pull
up this story and we'll get into the uh
I'll I'll add to that
there's an overlap between
the left and the the trans the
transgenderism ideologues like the
gender ideology thing and there has been
a high degree of violence we have seen
coming from many of these individuals
but they also talk about it openly with
like Stonewall they say it was trans
women throwing bricks at cops and things
like that so it's no surprise that you
got that horrifying tragic event on
Monday let's jump to this story from the
post-millennial breaking trans male
arrested for planning Colorado school
shooting had anti-trump Manifesto
Whitworth faces charges of attempted
murder after allegedly making threads
against schools in Colorado Springs
Colorado this is crazy so this is a
biological mail who is trans identified
his name is William Whitworth was
arrested and charged after police
investigation in Colorado Springs
revealed the 19 year old was responsible
for threats involving schools in
Colorado Springs Academy District 20.
the Heber County Sheriff's Office
charged with two counts of criminal
attempt to commit murder in the first
degree criminal mischief menacing and
interference with staff faculty or
students of educational institutions now
apparently I would say based on this
reporting this must have happened well
before the the mass shootings that we
saw in Nashville
however
when this individual in Nashville is
being called a victim by the Nashville
protesters by the Nashville I'm sorry
insurrectionist to storm the capital
they held up seven fingers right
symbolizing that the individual who
committed the mass reading was also a
victim how many more people have leftist
persuasion will will think to themselves
if that if they do this they will also
be celebrated
well transgenderism the extremism it's
it relies on violence to get its way and
the era of violence when you tell
all your supporters and and folks going
through this like this young man that
critics of you or those who don't share
your views are
but their their criticism is violence
genocide you know that that that it it
puts a Target on people's back that you
you don't agree with me that means
you're vile and if you're violent you
don't deserve protection and I can
defend myself against you if you're a
fascist you're outside the protection of
the law and we can go after you and be
violence This Is How They frame it they
frame it as though it is self-defense
right when you say words right so words
are violence you're all a Target America
you're all a Target
me not to see
a martyrdom component to this too like
if you feel like you are depressed and
you've got all these questions about who
you are and your gender and your online
community is telling you there there is
a need to take action now that in some
way you might find that you are uh
pursuing
you know basically immortality through a
terrible act and that
you know for the rest of us would deter
you from doing this but if you're in a
psychologically Disturbed State you see
it as the ultimate called action which
is tragic and it can it's terrible
imagine imagine if you've been ripped
away from your biological reality but
that's what's happened to these folks
they've been caught up in this the
thrall of this extremism and everything
that people rely on to get through life
you know
I'm comfortable I it may I mean you know
I am what I am like True North yeah
everything everything and of course
that's the Communist way right they want
to take everything away from you so you
rely on them and their ideology
ultimately and that means tearing apart
the family the institutions that compete
with the state religion uh and also uh
tearing tearing you away from your
biology I mean that that would be the
best victory for the left well think
about nothing nothing is certain and the
only thing is certain is this
Consciousness that we will raise for you
through the Marxist Revolution I think
it's
it's poised to shift at any moment into
who knows what there's there's no reason
in my opinion that it stays with just
the gender issue because we've also seen
transracialism and things like this now
they've been slow to actually accept it
but it seems like they may be getting
towards accepting it because according
to their ideology they have no choice
but to accept it right the the argument
being that
if anyone can identify as whatever they
want
if a person appears white but agrees
with them ideal ideologically and claims
to be black then they must be they are
and so the door has been opened
completely to even transracialism now
you're starting to see universities and
that blows up our anti-discrimination
laws right yeah if you go in there and
you identify as a black owned business
who's to say you're not well Serge is
African-American that is correct I am
yep South Africa yeah
I understand but yeah and and uh you
know and that they kind of deny they're
rejecting all these fundamentals they
don't believe in Racial equality they
don't they believe in racial
discrimination they absolutely do not
believe in racial and I tell you and I
tell you this transgenderism the
targeting of children and the
endorsement of Mutilation of children I
mean that's demonic and uh if there's a
way to kind of denote something as being
good versus bad the this the targeting
of children in this way uh and the
endorsement of it by our political class
you know well countries can't survive
let's destroying their children let's
put it let's put it simply in
Scandinavian countries they have stopped
gender affirmation as they call it for
minors they have stopped the the
countries the left claims or the
bastions uh the examples of good health
care have said hey this actually was not
helping yet for some reason and it's and
I think it's because the left is a cult
it doesn't matter what's true and
correct it doesn't matter what's logical
what matters is they gain power and the
cult says it's so so be it even if they
want to come out and say Sweden and
Denmark are so great okay well Sweden
and Denmark said stop doing this no they
won't well you know I'm convinced that
you can't an adult
for themselves or certainly for a minor
cannot give informed consent to these
this transgender trans you know
surgeries uh whatever you want to call
it and the fact that it's allowed both
legally or medically is a problem has to
be dealt with but no one should be no
one can do it under traditional medical
ethics no doctor can do it and it
shouldn't be allowed legally adults and
children because it's it's like someone
someone could you know someone going
into a doctor and saying I want you to
cut off both my arms that should not be
allowed to happen
and and the idea that someone can
ethically do that as a doctor or that
someone can consent to that under
traditional standards of uh informed
consent laws and under and ethics it's
it's at odds with everything we know
about medical but but see the question I
have with this when it comes to adults
is what is the ethical line and so I can
certainly understand we're living
someone's arms because that makes them
that makes them dependent to a certain
degree but if someone goes in and says
that they want to be sterilized they can
still use their arms to eat sleep work
and do whatever I mean if a human adult
wants to split their tongue or get
tattoos or remove an earlobe or whatever
it's kind of like
people do a lot of weird body
modification stuff well what is the
treatment what is the treatment they're
seeking and what is it what is it
designed designed to solve but doctors
can't just do medical procedures that
don't work but but my my issue is the
the what is the line to which someone is
allowed to modify their body surgically
I don't know what the line is but I do I
mean just because I don't know what the
line is right now does it mean that it
ought to be legal to have you go in and
have a doctor mutilate
mutilate your body to treat your
transgender dysphoria that's that's the
opposite of what should be done
medically and it should be prohibited
under law just like other radical
surgeries would be prohibited in similar
circumstances what about tongue forking
well I don't know what the medical
treatment is what what's the consequence
of that happening and frankly it's not
something that doctors typically do is
it or is it something that it can be
done outside of a surgical I'm not
entirely sure there's also
um magnetic implants I tell you what
I'll let you do ton tongue forking if
you stop mutilating babies and children
and allowing adults to have their
private parts torn apart but we're not
talking about kids in this context well
I'm talking about adults having their
private parts torn apart but they're
choosing it I don't it doesn't matter no
one can ethic no one can Pro no one can
sensibly choose that I think you have to
talk about why right like if an adult
woman no she doesn't want to have kids
and she wants to get sterilized okay
maybe she does have a reason to go in
and get a hysterectomy right but a lot
of the justification for the body the
genital mutilation or the general
modification done to adults or children
is we're preventing suicide and the idea
is that death is worth sin potentially
you know living without an organ being
dependent on hormones anything like that
I think if you want to get your tongue
Fork because you know you want it and
it's not going to potentially completely
impair your life forever then that's a
very different thing than saying if you
don't let me get my tongue forked I will
die because you probably won't die sure
but that's that's an entirely different
argument I mean if someone went to it
but I'm saying like you can't I said
simply uh so I I know people who have
gotten hysterectomies because they said
they just don't they want it done end of
story have a nice day I don't care and
then they've gotten the surgery and it's
like you're a 30 year old adult you've
made the choice for yourself you will
not have kids but you can still walk run
jump eat sleep work the only thing
that's happening is you can't reproduce
anymore it's kind of like
people get their tubes tied all the time
people you know get a vasectomies the
question is what's the line now cutting
off someone's arms well now you're
creating an issue for society where
someone's going to be requiring
assistance and that is like okay that
that's that's that's where the line is
that I see I do think that there's a
problem with that I I just want to be
clear
no one can give informed consent
to gender mutilation surgery no one can
give informed consent so the law can't
allow you to do it doctors can't
lawfully or ethically do it and
certainly government shouldn't be
subsidizing it and promoting it with
children because well if you allow
adults to do it
to solve a medical problem right well
why well what if a child has a similar
quote medical problem the suicide the
suicide now now you know this is this is
this is another big issue so we now give
you whatever you want in terms of
medical treatment because you're so far
gone psychologically and emotionally you
could commit suicide otherwise that
start in the night that's like a hostage
situation that's not medical treatment
they started to have to treat but I I
don't want to conflate
the claiming children can get sex
changes with a legal adult doing
whatever they want well they conflate it
so you need to understand I totally get
it and so I have I have a line there
where I'm like do I think people who are
adults should undergo body modification
at all no I think it's all bad but uh
okay if you're gonna if you're gonna go
you know get strange body modifications
because you want to look or feel a
certain way it's just kind of like
I don't know man that's just me I've
never been staunchly conservative in
that but going after kids is the line I
mean look at this still in Mulvaney
right
everything he's about is the targeting
of children absolutely everything he he
when he talks about my 365 days as a
girl what what adult female
maybe I don't know somebody saying girl
he's already talking about minors what
adult females go around talking about
girls in a regular way other than in a
joking way he is not joking and he and
he acts like a teenager he acts like a
young a young female act like a teenager
acts like a little girl well he doesn't
even act like any he doesn't act like a
caricature a caricature of what he
thinks a woman or a girl is but he's
targeting children let's let's jump to
the story from billboard Travis Tritt
Cuts all Anheuser-Busch products from
his tour writer following Brands
trans-inclusive campaign
so it's not just Travis Tritt I believe
John Rich uh Kid Rock obviously and uh
apparently many others uh Travis Tritt
is saying there's many other artists who
are just totally getting rid of
Anheuser-Busch we're also hearing that
tons of liquor stores bars are getting
rid of Anheuser-Busch products we heard
that in Saint I think it was in Saint
Louis uh no no it wasn't it was in
Missouri somewhere they shut down a
Budweiser Clydesdale event because of
the backlash they've been receiving over
the sponsorship of Dylan Mulvaney so
what is the sponsorship now I think this
is something you can educate people on
so is he sponsored in the sense he given
cash or given does it get cash for
selling it on on estimates are fifty
thousand dollars for Dylan Mulvaney to
do a video drinking Budweiser so he gets
does he get video does he get cash from
people viewing it
Budweiser called them called Dylan
mulvanian said we will give you fifty
thousand dollars to make a video oh so
he got money just to do what he did
because he's an influencer they're
paying 10 million 11 million followers
yeah they're paying for time on his
social media so he's not getting a
commission he just got the money just
the money so uh I wanna I wanna stress
this to us often do I do not believe
that Dylan Mulvaney is a transgender
individual I believe that Dylan Mulvaney
if you look at I talked about this
earlier actually uh Dylan Mulvaney is
phase two of what is known as Elsa gate
it is the next level of what Elsa gate
is uh are you familiar with Elsa gate no
so when YouTube enacted its algorithm or
to a certain degree the algorithm got to
a point where people were using computer
programs to Auto generate videos that
would fall in line with the algorithm to
maximize viewership so they'd make money
when what ended up happening was there
was a wave of videos America well it
wasn't America if you know what I mean
it was uh it was like it was it was
mainly India I believe the market works
there were videos emerging where Elsa
was eating feces out of the toilet
getting injected with blood syringes and
giving birth then there was the Lesser
videos where it's like the Joker
Spider-Man and Elsa were running through
houses and doing weird things but many
of the videos depicted strange little
cartoon people eating and drinking out
of toilets being injected and having
other grotesque things done to them
bleeding from their mouth teeth being
ripped out and it was because these
things triggered the triggered the
algorithm so when parents would give
their iPad to a baby
and Press Play in a nursery rhyme and
then leave they hear some woman being
like hello little baby let's sing a song
and they're like that sounds wholesome
they leave the room
the video ends five minutes later
YouTube then Auto plays whatever fits
the algorithm after about five videos
you are in the insane world of Elsa
eating feces this this is Elsa gate this
is what happened yeah so what happens
with Dylan Mulvaney is that Tick Tock
makes an algorithm Dylan Mulvaney was
making a series of content like animals
nature didn't work
did it coming out as as a non-binary got
a few hundred thousand views did a
full-on day one of being a girl got
millions of views Dylan Mulvaney then
says ding light bulb this is what works
Dylan Mulvaney then decides to pursue
this course of content and then slowly
begin the process of doing drugs and
whatever to fit that mold to make money
hence Dylan Mulvaney prancing around in
the woods wearing high heels is not
something a trans individual does or a
woman does it is a caricature and it is
a real-life version of Elsa gate the
algorithm mashed these things together
and Dylan mulvani said if I do this I'll
get clicks so to any sane adult seeing
an adult human male taking hormones and
getting surgery putting on high heels
and running through the woods you'd be
like okay hold on this is really really
weird but all of these different things
combined make the algorithm promote it
so this individual gets views and then
pursues doing more of it this is what
Bud Light sponsored so for most of us we
are saying rational adults we see Elsa
eating feces and we go something's wrong
this is this is not right kids should
not be watching this we then see Dylan
Mulvaney and say okay this is not what
women do this is really weird what is
this
but young people don't know the
difference so when babies were being fed
elseigate they just watched it
when young pre-teens and teenagers on
Tick Tock see Dylan Mulvaney they just
watch it but where where are the adults
and Budweisers say that I'm assuming the
way it works is they've got their
marketers right who are in the thrall of
whatever you know fattest social media
especially to the the more to the left
the more politically correct the better
but isn't there an adult who says no no
we don't do this the adults are
millennials you know you can't do this
the Millennials I I think this is the
most fear-based decision-making where
where the my view is the leadership of
Anheuser-Busch needs to be held
accountable for allowing this to happen
because I think they know better
and they're afraid of
I don't agree the thugs in their own
offices I think imposed this thinking on
them I think it's going to get worse and
I think it's much much much more simple
than that
the 35 year old woman who got promoted
two years ago to a marketing manager for
Bud Light is running the room right now
and saying this Dylan Mulvaney has 11
million followers let's do this campaign
that's all that happened the people at
the top the executives at budweis are
probably older gen xers and some Boomers
probably have no idea what the campaign
was but they certainly learned about it
now and now they're saying what is going
on and it's going to get worse
Millennials were raised on these
algorithms it was 10 years ago it was 15
years ago we're talking about 2006 2007
the emergence of social media algorithms
people who are getting out of college
create an existence on Facebook where
they're fed nothing but this
intersectional feminist garbage because
the algorithms were sending that kind of
content if the only thing you see for 10
years is that the United States is white
supremacist then you are going to live
in a world where that's true you've seen
nothing but evidence proving it now
you're 30 years old you're working as a
you know you're working at a low entry
level position at Budweiser at
Anheuser-Busch now you're 35. you've
been given a promotion you are now head
of marketing for your division
it's that simple and then this person is
in charge and they fill it out now it's
possible the rumor is that at
Anheuser-Busch they're reeling from this
and the executives are furious at this
person someone posted the LinkedIn for
the woman who runs marketing I guess and
it's like a 35 year old Millennial woman
I think what's going to happen is there
may be a reprimand here if enough people
boycott Anheuser-Busch products to the
point where they're forced to issue an
apology they have if they don't answer
an apology they'll wait for it all to
blow over but if conservatives and
anti-woke individuals hold that for a
long enough period of time and say we
will not buy any of these products and
then the end of next quarter comes and
their stock drops because of it their
share prices then they issue an apology
and that creates cultural ripples
however
it is going to be a genzir who replaces
as Millennial woman and that gen zir is
going to have more hyper radical views
it is not in my opinion that some guy at
Bush at Anheuser Bush was like you know
we should go after young people and hire
Dylan Mulvaney it was a young person
hired who said this is what's popular
let's do it do you remember a couple
years ago I mean probably a long time
ago at this point there was that Kendall
Jenner Pepsi ad that got a lot of
backlash where there's like a protest
and magically Kendall Jenner gender Saul
she saves the day she saves the day I
don't know what her name is no gender
um but they she like passes over a Pepsi
can and everything is good and that was
widely balanced as being you know so
ridiculous so brave just mocking sort of
social justice efforts whatever
I worked at a PR firm at that time and
we had a whole discussion as a company
on it being like what did we learned
from this that this was a terrible idea
great how could we have stopped this
literally talking to anyone else in the
room but it's you know they'll have
these marketing teams that are like I
think this could be cool and we can get
Kendall Jenner and they're like oh my
gosh great idea and none of them can see
past it so what they know is that is
trending and they're like well might as
well jump on this bandwagon they can't
see the consequences I disagree it is a
millennial woman who likes Dylan Mulvane
that's what I'm saying it's all the
millennial women in the same room being
like still moving he's cool right so
it'll work it'll be fine and they're not
thinking about the consequences
if we got dull mulvani to drink Bud
Light for March Madness that is
brilliant oh my God and now you've got
some 58 year old dude in in the upstairs
being like what am I what is Kid Rock
doing he's shooting our product why is
he doing that and they'll be like well
because you've got this histrionic
sociopath yeah drinking your beer and
now people are it's soft was buying Bud
Light
what about the Nike ad oh yeah but let
me let me let me let me put this simple
for everybody to understand
there are a lot of people on the left
who are alike but it's so great that
Dylan Mulvaney is having fun and
drinking beer okay how would you feel if
Bud Light did a sponsorship of Infowars
and Alex Jones came out with a pack of
Bud Light and said Bud Light sponsor in
the show thanks Anheuser-Busch you're
the best and then and then he stabs it
shotguns it Slams on the ground raw rips
his shirt off we'd probably laugh right
but the left would lose their minds
sponsoring someone who is culturally
divisive is probably a very bad idea
which is funny because companies tend to
avoid those sponsorships it's cancel
culture they're like f we work with this
company you know we're going to get in
trouble
so going for Dylan Mulvaney was like
what did Stephen Colbert call it
sticking your dick into a hornet's nest
that's what he called it 10 years ago
with HB Gary I'll use the same analogy
that's what they did yeah and I think
because they don't have anyone their act
who's actually buying their product in
their marketing rooms when they're
having this conversation no one is like
that's a bad idea they're all talking to
each other they all watch the same kinds
of content online and so therefore
they're all attracted to the same
influencers and in this case it's a
radical divisive figure but there's no
one in there who probably drinks Bud
Light regularly who is like this won't
sell to anyone please stop immediately
there's no check in balance system in
the marketing agency yeah and if it were
only interested in advertising
controversy it'd be one thing but you
know you had the Supreme Court cave in
to the transgender extremists by
refusing to protect women and girls in
West Virginia from having to compete
against boys temporary though I mean
that officially hasn't gone through its
ruling this is just saying that that
rule can be enforced right now no that
the rule can't be enforced right now the
world can't be foreign
Patrick Morrissey argue in front of the
case yet but you know typically the
courts intervene when there's a
likelihood of danger and this is
dangerous the the celebrate Easter
evidently uh the bite Administration
just issued a rule demanding all federal
funded programs sporting programs uh uh
refused to protect little girls by
requiring males to be allowed to
participate so this is a fanaticism and
as I keep on saying it's it's a
dangerous extremism
because it relies on this implication of
Violence by your opponents and it's the
and and it and it
focuses on
grooming children I want to jump to this
other story you were mentioning a moment
ago that the left isn't they don't
actually care about uh racism or I
forgot exactly how you phrased it but
basically the view is the the woke left
they're actually very racist then I have
proof we have the story from bounding
into Comics Dungeons and Dragons to
remove half species from players
handbook claims the entire idea is
inherently racist wow
so let me put it simply the idea that
there are mixed race species in the
world of Dungeons and Dragons they deem
should not be in the game anymore
because it is racist oh yeah yeah they
are saying that race mixing is racist
you don't think that's the breeze half
the reason for the hatred for Clarence
Thomas
Clarence Thomas is married to oh I'm
friends with Jenny Jenny Thomas a white
woman AOC that is a major major issue
sort of I mean aoc's uh I don't know
fiance or her husband I don't know if
they're married is white and Kamala
Harris is married to a white guy or
whatever right so well what does aoc's
ethnicity she's uh she's what is she
she's Latina she's a Latina but I don't
know like of what persuasion but she's
she's not white I mean the left
considers Latinos white if they vote
Republican
and they consider black people white if
they Republican too I don't know
that's why I'm confused but so so this
this one was really funny to me when I
saw this wizard of the coast revealed
that they will be removing the concept
of half species from The Dungeons and
Dragons players handbook on the grounds
they are not comfortable including an
inherently racist Concept in the game
what what's racist about mixed race
characters I I wonder is something wrong
well the the the the racial fanaticism
that really bugs me is the decision to
capitalize black and white
oh yeah in description which is straight
out of South speaking of African yeah
straight out of South Africa apartheid
did you see that uh that judge who I
guess I don't know what the story was he
reprimanded the uh the woke uh the
lawyer for his pronouns in the in the
pleading he said you're adding extra
words for no reason an attempt to
persuade uh uh an officer of the Court
by in making political implications you
capitalize the word black but not white
oh that was a different one yeah I
thought no the same one oh yeah yeah and
then the the it was like it was a
prosecutor or something he put pronouns
in it and the judge basically said that
including your pronouns only attempts to
signal to the court that you are of a
political persuasion to seek favor we
have a case in Minnesota public teachers
union in Minneapolis
they put in a contract that you know if
there's a layoff you get laid off
usually the most recent
employee you know the most recent hire
first in first out right you don't have
the EXP you have to be on the job longer
in order to get the benefit of not
getting laid off except if you're black
or white
so if you're a black person who
otherwise would be fired they go to the
next person who's white and fires them
yeah and on the back end rehiring it's
usually you know the most senior person
gets first unless they're the wrong
color so this is there's this it's not
it's it's not like they in favor racial
discrimination they embrace it and they
reject
the Constitutional prohibitions on
racial discrimination and the civil
rights laws of the 60s they don't
believe in them it's been this way since
I was a kid they don't believe in them
this is how Chicago has always operated
as long as I've been alive this has been
a component that friends of mine and my
family have have dealt with that if you
were white
if you were perceived as white they
would skip you in in public hiring or
public promotions and that was that was
normal well you know but that's an
internal ethnic issue in Chicago versus
a public school Union with the
endorsement of the city engaging in
Brazen no I'm talking about police and
fire department right outright saying
white people need not apply oh right
right with the with the racial quotas at
the time right and California they had
quota requirements for private boards
they said you you had to have so if you
have a just you know a quota means that
someone gets a job
that no one else can apply for because
of their race or whatever the quota
requirements that's a huge thing is
South Africa as well as racial quotas
it's like one of the major things
honestly but in South Africa do they
have quote the quotas apply to white
people uh yes it's like you have to hire
I believe it's like every which I hire
one white person entire three black
people and they could be black people
with any every any tribe doesn't matter
but they have to be three black or
colored people in that position so no
matter what even and this is important
for people to understand colored means
something specific in South Africa yes
colored is a proper word capital c o l o
u r e d colored it refers to mix mixed
race right yes correct who speak
Afrikaans it's like their main language
yeah that's that's funny because in the
United States it's just considered like
a slur or an insult right but in South
Africa it's like a legal term it's
illegal it's the the name they use for
themselves yes and it's capitalized
that's why I was talking about the
capitalization of race is pernicious uh
that you know like I keep on saying they
don't believe in any of the kind of
well what the liberal basis for our
country has been for the last 50 60
years that we're supposed to be treating
people according to something other than
their race or or sex or now you know
lgbqt status or whatever it's you you
get special treatment and others get
punished
uh it is it is a um you know how how is
it you run a Civil Society on that basis
I have no idea South Africa tried it
didn't work yeah it's uh it's I don't
think it's working
right I mean it didn't work under
apartheid and it didn't work in the
efforts to undo apartheid where they're
as race conscious in theory as they were
during the apartheid it's it's more race
conscious than it ever has been I think
and uh it's not helping
it's never helped I just I just with
this DND thing there's no other way to
see it they are white supremacists
and they are projecting to protect
themselves this is what the left does
they create segregated spaces there was
the famous uh Library I think was
Seattle where they had
um POC non-poc Library meetings yeah so
it's like well if you're white when I
was at um just to remember it's schools
across the country they engage in
segregation these safe whenever you hear
Affinity space sub segregation
who sued because her child who was black
was taken out of the mixed classroom and
put into an all-black class and she was
like why and they're like for his safety
and she's like what that's what they're
doing so these people are like we
shouldn't allow anyone to play a
character who's actually mixed race
because
race mixing is racist they say they're
trying to alter the culture to change
people's perceptions and it seems like
what they what sort of Communism is that
I'm trying to think through a Communists
I know but what I mean the com there's
communism behind it I'm just trying to
think through what is it's what is what
sort of Communism is it evidencing what
do you mean that this racialism
prohibits race mixing
is
I don't even understand it from the
Market's perspective because if there
isn't one the only underlying ideology
to what they're saying is they don't
want people to mix to raise you that's
just just like a vicious racism and
they're doing it under the guise of
fighting Against Racism this is what
they have always done they say we are
not racist it's actually Larry Elder
who's a white supremacist right
there you go now I read this uh article
I think in the root a long time ago
about a woman saying like we shouldn't
glorify black men dating uh
light-skinned black women or women who
are not like black women of a dark skin
tone because it's encouraging uh this
idea that black women aren't enough and
they they're it was like this this
argument that I found very interesting
because they're saying basically we want
to see people of the same race together
when it applies to this racial group I
mean in Harry Potter the people who were
encouraging just purebloods were the bad
guys and it seems like in a couple years
we've turned away from this well you
know and it's interesting because you
have this on the other hand this kind of
crazed commercial uh interest in
depicting interracial families
as if you know the to me it's kind of
Reverse Racism as if they're too afraid
to depict
uh uh an entire black family or an
entire white family but you know the
only reason the black person can get in
the commercial if they're married to a
white person these days I mean it's it's
I mean this is where we are yeah and and
I think it's and it doesn't make you
know and I guess the communism is it
doesn't make sense it's disruptive and
the goal is to destroy the system my
chaos is key I think I think the
Communists who are racist Marx was
racist Shea was racist racist and they
are racists and what they're doing is
they're encouraging policies that
enhance racial tensions and and they
actively promote segregation they're
they're white supremacists feigning a
guilty conscience yeah the left the left
is long used racial division to you know
to to advance the revolution if I put it
this way Democrats
if I were to tell you that Democrats
were imposing racist policy if you were
not American all right you've never
heard of the country and you started
reading the history of this country then
you showed up here on you know you land
at JFK and you walk out and you're like
wow America first time here and someone
came to you and said Democrats are
racist what would that person say
well they're supporting well a person
who doesn't know has never hasn't read a
book about the United States they'd say
that is correct they would say they
support yes I read this book I know
exactly what you're talking about right
they supported slavery they supported
Jim Crow uh they opposed the civil
rights movement and now they're
reimposing segregation in school
districts the country and apparently
people have left us persuasion think
race mixing is racist yeah that's they
don't really think it's racist they just
want an excuse to get rid of it the core
love story of Lord of the Rings is a
race mix it's a human and an elf it's
all you can't have that yeah we could
see and I could see in 20 years that
they're like we got to rewrite that it's
no good this is uh Hasbro Wizards the
coast is owned by Hasbro I believe
directly and then they're they're funded
by the Vanguard group where they
actually owned by Vanguard BlackRock
Capital research Global Investors the
three of those companies own about 30
percent of Hasbro then there's this guy
Alan G hassenfeld who owns six percent
of the company so it's like
multinational corporations that are
talking about how to people of different
races finding love together or coming
together right you know and they don't
want people to love each other they want
everyone to be angry at each other you
know I get the whole idea anything that
shuts us that you rise above
in a spiritual or moral way uh you know
the divisions that you know keep us you
know uh sinned or sinful it's something
to left oppose that they want to raise
everything that hurts America hurts
human beings I could get the argument
make that there or make that their basis
if they were to say like oh well it's
because of an orc took a human woman
back to his tribe and raped you know I'm
like they're they're no no they're
saying that to imply that an elf who is
half human is only half elf is racist
because he's an elf oh like they could
call it a half human that's good the
whole game is written from the human
perspective no no that's not what
they're saying they're saying uh Alpha
has to be able to identify as a full Elf
yes you can't treat them as negative you
get Elven abilities when you have a half
when you have an elderly father that's
how it works you get a half night vision
just saying you have infrared vision
they are saying if a person is half elf
they are Elf that's it but if that's not
quite though that's what they're saying
right now I understand they're trying to
change it to they are changing it so
they're saying if you well what about a
quarter elf nope nope you're still an
elf you're still enough that would
actually be illogical this is the racial
tenants of the Democrats hundreds of
years ago
and we laugh at it but it's I mean the
extremism is a feature the you know it's
oh yeah you know we say well it's a
slippery slope and it's like yeah I mean
they they you know we laugh but they say
yeah this of course is this is logical
to us and you know you're going to get
with the program we're going to make you
get with the program I understand the
human-centric thing and maybe that's a
mistake because you could have like a
half orc half elf person
uh they don't have to be human so maybe
they could they should have went that
they should go in that direction where
you could have like a Dwarven elf a
dwarf an elf yeah that'd be cool did you
say you only get night vision if your
dad's well elves have night they have
infrared vision they can see in low
light vision they can see up to 60. it's
only passed paternally Oh either either
as long as you have Elven blood you're
able you have some of the Elven ability
uh but I would love to see the game go
like more race mixing like a Dwarven orc
you know I have to work
for them I guess wouldn't it be amazing
they wouldn't be comfortable one of my
great grandmother was an elephant but my
great-grandfather was an orc and my my
other great grandmother was a human
they're just writing this these kinds of
characters out of the game or
if you go back in time to when there was
racial segregation the the the the rules
they imposed the racist was basically
like if any part of you is non-white
then you are not white yeah and so
they're literally doing implementing
this right now like you're not a human
you're an elf it's like no but I'm half
no you're not you're an elf like you're
not human that's what they're basically
saying
if you have a human mother and an elf
father I mean let's just let's just this
is funny let's just say that their
ideology of what they're explaining
let's replace human and elf with just
like
um Indian and Japanese
what they're basically saying is that
one one group looks at the individual of
two races and just asserts they can only
be one imagine there was a kid and
that's how it works in the United States
Barack Obama is black despite the fact
that he's half white right that's the
view of the left he is not white he is
black and that's that that's in in this
world that's all he's allowed to be to
me that's crazy
but that's that's how they've always
viewed it because they're racist yeah
there you go I'm holding out for the
quarter elves I want to see if they can
see 15. I'll tell you this I'll tell you
this uh when I was younger is it racist
or racialist
you know racists I'm always a little
hesitant about the racism because it is
racist because the racism suggests that
someone has negative characteristics
because of their race as opposed to
being obsessed with race per se and
using that and I'm being charitable
frankly I'm just Rising a point I think
I I believe it's generally racist it is
but there's this but I think there's
this broader issue of racialism
that is that is part of the the Marxist
effort to destroy the country by
categorizing us whether we want to or
not and putting some people into good
boxes and other people into bad boxes
and um you know what they run into I
think in their racialism and this
probably explains this is that folks of
mixed Races they aren't quite sure what
to do so now they've got their Rule and
you're going to go into one box or the
other it's all because if you straddle
the boxes then the whole the whole it's
always been this way the whole construct
a lot it's always been this way and it's
never been you're one of the other
you're always the other with growing up
this was explicit to me because I have I
have a a Korean mom I will never be
white according to the government I am
not white I can't be white I can never
identify as white even though I'm more
white than Asian I am Asian end of story
and what would you now on the Korean
side how would Koreans consider you
white
they would they say you're white even I
mean
uh my understanding Koreans are a bit
different they're very racist very very
racial supremacist so they would find
Value in the fact that I'm part Korean
and be like oh wow but lesser than them
so it's not it's not so much among the
younger generation of Koreans right but
the you know like 50 like the older you
get in terms of Korea the more racial
supremacists they are and the Korean
supremacists they that Koreans older
ones genuinely believe Koreans are the
Supreme race no joke and it it emerged
my understanding not just over whites
but other Asians as well everyone they
believe they're the superior rest of the
planet and the reason they do my
understanding is that when Japan invaded
and and you know colonized parts of Asia
the Japanese claimed that they were the
Supreme Race So Korean resistance
countered this by claiming to their
children and Fighters no it's actually
us and we'll prove it then when Japan
ultimately gets repelled in the koreas
you know everything happens it happens
they retained that view that they were
supreme but I gotta tell you when I went
to Seoul one of the funniest things I've
seen was in this Museum talking about
the great Naval general or whatever and
its tremendous victories over Japan but
as you go step by step through his
career it's like a great victory was had
here and it shows like 50 Korean ships
fighting 50 Japanese ships and then it's
like and he was Victorious and then you
jump like a year and it's like in the
next great battle he won and there's
like 10 Korean ships and 50 Japanese
ships and it's like so you're saying
that for every five battles he lost he
won one and you're only showing me the
ones he won I thought that was actually
kind of funny I was like what else are
you gonna do like we lost a lot the
Japanese took over and you know so with
the d d game which one is better like to
your point if they're half elf half orc
you want to be half do you want my
characters half elf it depends on how
you want to play the game okay
yeah and Orcs are stronger but the game
doesn't naturally favor one or the other
so like in the half elf house half human
thing it you said it was written from a
human's perspective yeah so it's better
to be well humans don't have any they're
like the most Bland General character
they don't really have a lot of bonuses
or a lot of negatives so it would be
better to be lumped in with the elves
because they're more powerful no because
they're they can they die they have less
hit points they're physically speaker
but they're quicker or they're they're
better with magic but you can if you hit
them they die quicker okay let's let's
let's let's just get off the dungeon and
Dragons for a bit we'll jump back to
possible there's a big movie out that's
right oh yeah well we got this you fell
into it this is a big story we got well
it just shows the culture of what
they're creating yeah they should call
the movie Dungeons and Dragons that's
the concept of the worlds that you can
create a movie about like the movie
should be called something awesome the
realm and then somewhere in there
Dungeons and Dragons property it does it
is called something and they put d d
above it but let's jump to the store and
talk politics we have this from WEAR
news ABC3 former Congressional candidate
Rebecca Jones son arrested in Santa Rosa
County this is a Democrat uh she was
like this fake whistleblower I guess I
don't know uh most of the detail it's
been a while but she ran as a Democrat
she is now accusing what does she what
did she say Rhonda status kidnapped her
son the true story is that let me let me
just uh we'll jump over here
the government of Florida oh the
government of Florida so here's a tweet
from the Miami Herald 13 year old son of
Rebecca Jones whistleblower who clashed
with the santis arrested over memes
memes here's what community notes added
an incident report released Thursday
afternoon by the Santa Rosa's Sheriff's
Office allege that the 13-year-old made
repeated threats to shoot up Holly
Navarre middle school and to stab
students who angered him he also talked
about being on antidepressants that
weren't working so that's why he got
arrested right now this Rebecca Jones
woman she's blocked me by the way she is
posting up a storm claiming that here's
here's she said two weeks later bringing
us to early today an officer told me the
state issued a warrant for my son's
arrest for digital threats of terrorism
I asked on Whose orders the officer said
it was the state they aren't letting him
come home tonight they kidnapped my son
it's called arrested lady and now she
got a whole bunch of Democrats and
leftists being like this is Rondo Santos
he's a fascist this is the Miami Herald
suggested that he was arrested for a
political statement right yes when in
fact it was terroristic threats online
allegedly yeah but when I looked this up
the Pensacola News Journal was the one
right under it and they're like that's
what she's claiming but let's talk about
what actually happened they have like a
list of his statements that he made so
this is a person Rebecca John she's the
one who accused the sadness of hiding
covet numbers yeah yeah yeah yeah hey
these are red flag laws why why is this
lady complaining her kid got red flagged
baby and the cops came and arrested him
this is exactly what Democrats have been
asking for why wasn't she concerned
about her son's death threats because
she's she's evil these people are evil
bro it was a rhetorical question no but
there's an answer because we talk about
this so often when I point out here is a
woman who knows full well what her son
did right she is capitalizing off of the
fact that her son is reported to have
threatened to murder classmates and
she's using it for political power
she tweeted before I'm getting out of
Florida or something like this and then
she never did now why would she say such
a thing and then not follow through oh
because they're Liars because she's
lying then when her son gets arrested
because the family is clearly unwell she
says they kidnapped my son and she's got
followers who are eating it up and she
is using this stuff for political gain
well I hope his her son gets a lawyer
that represents his interest in a way
that's better than his mother's doing
yeah
that he was being homeschooled
homeschool I'm his arrest which like to
me sometimes implies that kids are were
are being homeschooled for other issues
they're being kept from school I'd like
to just point out Jazz Jennings mother
and that viral video did you see the
viral video where Jazz's mother says she
wakes up Jasmine the middle of the night
with the dilator and lubricates it and
says if you don't stick this in I will
so the point here is oh thank God I've
missed that the degree to which these
people are willing to go to cause human
suffering if it empowers them in some
way is terrifying
and right now you have a woman whose son
is in jail for making terroristic
threats so it is so he is charged and
reported and she's using this for
personal gain instead of saying what's
going on between me and my family is
personal and private and I'd like to
keep it that way she rushes to social
media and says help help they kidnapped
my son clearly a lie but she's doing it
for political power and is it that the
son the heavyset person in that picture
no that's the images I think that's
Boogie
she was worried about her husband and
daughter safety didn't send them out of
the stage yeah they deflee it's just all
lies it's all lies it's all they do it
makes me sad for her kid right like if
this is how she's responding my kids
being unfairly kidnapped by the
government like if this kid really does
have some sort of issue apparently his
parents are not taking it as seriously
as they should they would rather point
the finger on the floor to government I
guess
I was uh when I when I started making
internet videos in 2006 it was new and I
was like wow I'm becoming a cult leader
this is very dangerous I don't want to
be this I don't want this power this
could easily corrupt me and make me tell
people to do something and destroy the
entire system I can't so I put it down
because it wasn't right but the only
problem is all these other people are
now picking it up and doing it and
they're not ethical you recognize that
people were paying attention to what you
said in a way that you didn't really
want them to they would yell my name
instead of the things I was talking
about right
it's but it's like if I don't do it
someone else is going to do it and I and
I don't trust these other weird like no
offense lady I don't know you Rebecca
but she's weird she's obviously
acknowledge your kid's problem if he was
threatening his classmates acknowledge
it he apparently I saw uh messages where
he said he was placed on antidepressants
but they weren't working
clearly this kid is unwell I feel bad
for him but
man he I can't even read what he said I
don't even think we could pull it up if
I show this YouTube's gonna freak out it
takes me back to the same solution every
time we talk about this kind of stuff is
that don't be a reactionary well I mean
it's okay to talk about crazy stuff that
happens but if you're just constantly
reacting to the bad stuff you need to
create the good stuff
that's the answer
you need to become the famous one you
need to be the one
I'm talking about what these people
think everyone's thinking it right now
and it is a culture War to seize power
well and when you see it and when you
see politicians Embrace a mass shooter
uh you know they talk about a contagion
you know the other folks look at that
and say well I can get similar positive
feedback if I go and murder people these
are dangerous dangerous uh positions for
look at John Brown yeah the story of
John Brown is not a good one I mean look
slavery was wrong no John Brown no one
no one I thought you meant John Brown
something happened just now but no John
Brown history John Brown went to Kansas
as kids and just started murdering
people John Brown walked up to a guy and
shot him in the face I mean look I get
it there are bad things they are evil
things
but it's like
I don't know man
the the their their questions about how
we handle the problems of of Greater
society and there is an interesting
question about was John Brown right to
just walk up to people I I think the
answer is freeing slaves without killing
a bunch of people for the sake of
killing them is probably the right way
to go about things this was before the
war this was before an attempt to end it
what we're seeing here is the next
degree these people who are planning
these things if it if this breaks into
Civil War they're already martyring
these people they stood in the Tennessee
legislature and they all stood there
silently holding up seven fingers
in in some kind of protest symbol like
Hunger Games representing that the
shooter themselves was a victim
that is scary yeah yeah and and the
irony is he was a victim of them
oh yeah yeah she's a victim of something
for sure like the parental lack of
Parental oversight you know I mean it
took 12 hours for me to even figure out
whether he was a he or she I mean that's
how crazed our media was that they
couldn't tell us with a straight
straight wet in a straight way
the gender the actual gender biologic of
the murderer
the sex yeah whatever the like straight
up I don't even know what word I'm
supposed to lie where am I supposed to
say yeah
everyone is so in fear of this
transgender extremism you can't even get
the who what when and why reporting for
hours well it's it's a fear of far left
terrorism
that's just plain and simple this is
what I've been saying I mean what they
talk about the islamists threatening and
curtailing Free Speech in Europe with by
murdering people who published the wrong
thing who was it recently on scientists
it was Richard Dawkins yeah Dawkins was
being interviewed by I think was it
Pierce where's Morgan this was nuts and
he says can you talk about Solomon
rushing he goes and he's like you don't
want to talk about it and then he's like
you are you worried about a backlash and
it goes I I don't want to talk about it
I I should have made that clear yeah
yeah and he's like well that's sad isn't
it he's like
sjk Rowling how she's doing in terms of
threats and stuff the point is I can't
imagine her security bills there's got
to be a way to talk about it with
empathy without saying I'm on that side
you don't have to take sides empathy
doesn't mean that you're that you
believe it's right or that you agree
with it it just means you understand and
I think there's a way but it's hard to
empathize with people that are on
psychotropics because they're not it's
hard you know it's hard it's not
impossible but it's hard
well they don't want to sympathize I
mean you know there's no there's no
a person of good faith who wasn't
concerned about someone who feels so
crazed about their
you know their body that they would
mutilate it or do these radical
procedures no one no one thinks well
it's good you feel that way and the
question is how how is it we treat it do
we help them or do we you know further
that extremism or that unhealth Matt
Walsh broke it down masterfully in that
recent College uh talk he gave where he
asked a person to explain how they knew
they were a woman and the person just
said because other trans people said
they felt similarly to me and he said
well that's how trans people heal but
not women and the person did not know or
ask how women actually felt what they
were actually saying is that it's kind
of sad the person just said that they
didn't fit in and they were trying to
find a community to fit into and they
did and and she was getting it or he or
she was getting ratified by her friends
said you're you're a girl and Walsh was
like of course they're going to be nice
to you they're your friends yeah and you
know in my view friends help you not
allow you to kind of yeah go down these
paths that are so if they're terrible in
the end if there was somebody who was
anorexic and you don't tell them and get
them help you're a bad person dude I
used to think if people changed their
name I'd be like what's up fake guy yeah
you're gonna go with a fake name now you
got a costume on like if you were a
beanie I'd be like fake I don't even I
don't even like nothing unless it's pure
real it's fake and then transgender came
along I'm like fake and then but then I
realized that's not the way like Mike
talked to Michael Mouse he's like it's
not it's not that big of a deal you can
have because I'm like what's up with
your fake name and he was like it's not
that dude it's not what you it's not
that big of a thing
and uh I don't know I was smoking a lot
of weed and I was like if it's not
exactly real aligned with God then it is
fake and needs to be flushed but I I
think there's more of a a Middle Road
you know no one's real all the time we
have clothing on you know we're not like
in the buff because that's real
I was I don't see how wearing clothes is
fake like you wear clothes to protect
ourselves from like the weather but like
people wear lipstick and it's like
that's like what's makeup I was so
anti-makeup I was just anything that's
not purely who you are was pissing me
off lipstick is simulating ovulation
isn't it probably yeah you're like and
same with blush is like the show that
you are living in that reality where I
was so anti-fake was like uh it was
anti-social I couldn't my friends were
like I don't want to be around it I'm
like you can't lie to her you need to
tell her that you slept around with uh
and he's like again I don't want you in
my life because I'm not gonna tell my
girlfriend I cheated on her I'm like
you're like an atomic bomb and people
honesty truth yes despite that like
honesty and Truth are valuable and
especially in Friendship you need to
have a an ability to speak honestly with
people right and I think that's what's
the difference between uh people who
feel as though they are not accepted
going online and thinking that they are
getting an honest reaction when they're
actually counting how many likes they
get or how many views their video gets I
think those are uh ways to trick your
brain having a dopamine reaction but
it's very different than if you had a
friend who was like well I want you to
be happy but I'm concerned I want you to
know that like you don't need to contort
yourself to be something you're not like
let let's work on your self-esteem
otherwise I think it's much easier and
sort of less
terrifying to seek gratification through
social media which isn't a completely
honest form of friendship you know what
I mean
my guess is he has a little bit of
talent there somewhere I disagree
there's somewhere there's something that
he's able you know he would if he was
channeling it directly he might be
successful in a way that would be in my
view appropriate but there's this crazed
approach uh and you know people are
going to be they're they're going to do
their own thing that's fine but stay
away from our kids don't ask us to
ratify it and don't create an entire
public policies around it I mean we're
now someone was telling me the other day
that a huge percentage of transgender
surgeries
are through the military
so what what's happening in our country
that it's you know and the numbers were
such that one could conclude that people
were only joining the military to get
the benefit of the surgery is it just
people in the military or is it also
their dependence because there have been
a couple like high profile cases of
military families well that's a that's a
fair question but the point was the
military is funding and I don't have the
exact number in front of me a
substantial portion of transgender
surgeries
uh annually in the United States it's
wild I'm glad you brought up Dylan
because I had that same thought earlier
where you guys were talking that he's
immensely talented but it's I feel like
this
immensely I'll say it because like
that's why he's famous right now is
because it's funny to watch to a lot of
people he dances really well he's a good
mover he has good physical form but he's
been he's gone into this realm of trying
to find clicks that's like I find it
shameful but I mean I'm not whatever you
but it is it's like don't twist things
just for for views and you're you are
incorrect
the videos of Dylan's are spaz stick
like I know it's like he's not rooted
it's not coordinated it's not good
movement it's it's random shaking
convulsing and screaming like The Price
is Right video it's just it is someone
who is it's not like he hasn't developed
more since then
it is someone who is a who is neglected
as a child and I mean I mean this with
full sincerity not to be mean I believe
that Dumbo venue was seriously neglected
and as a young child was not being given
attention so desperately lashed out
saying please please look at me
then goes on social media and tries
making different kinds of content to get
attention to be ostentatious The Price
is Right is the perfect example when Del
Mulvaney wins what does he do he runs
around for three minutes doing a weird
performance where he dances with the
pool stick saying please look at me it
is a strange narcissistic desire to be
looked at and it wasn't funny and it and
it wasn't even and what's happening now
is the only reason this content is
getting viewed is because the algorithm
on Tick Tock is pushing it that's it end
of story
I got banned from Tick Tock where band
as well
they didn't tell me why they just cut me
off we're gonna we're gonna go to Super
Chat so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this share with
your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member in order to
support our work by being a member and
clicking that join us button go to
timcast.com click join us you can get
access to the uncensored members only
show and if you join at least one 25
bucks or if you're a member at 10 bucks
for at least six months you get access
to the VIP chat room where you could
submit questions and potentially be
selected to call into the after show so
become a member over there for now we
will read your super chats
all right let's see what we got
oh where are we at
uh let's see
Damien Master says hey do you guys have
any plans to upload in 4k or 1440 would
be nice for bigger screens
I guess the issue is what is it what is
it now 1080 1080. we we did experiment
with 4K a while ago but it's massive in
terms of data consumption it's
ridiculously expensive it would take us
too long it's not that it would take us
too long it's that the data cost is just
to store it everything it's it's like
exponentially more expensive you're
talking about this show yeah for for any
live stream you'd understand that to
broadcast at 4K is X it's like it's like
the the broadcast rate squared do you
have the wiring to do that yes yeah but
it's an issue of cost yeah so for for if
we have we had like 40 some odd thousand
people watching it when we're doing the
after showing like YouTube is fine with
it there's two issues one the potential
constraint on our network if we push too
hard and then we start getting chopped
it starts chopping up most people don't
have 4K screens and storing it would be
very expensive and when we do the after
show we would have to switch to 1080
because we couldn't afford to broadcast
at 4K yeah so it's just like we just do
1080. you know what I mean heck we could
broadcast it for 480. now how far
how far are we away technologically and
cost wise from being able to take
advantage of the 4K like that I think
we're very far away and it may not
actually even happen they're right on
there because they're using photons
instead of electrons for circuitry so
that will change a lot it could and
there's also new compression technology
that comes out and reduces the the data
load and things like that but the issue
is the difference from 1080 on the
standard small screen to 4K is
indistinguishable for the most part to
people so when you're watching on your
phone where have people have people
watch or a small laptop screen yeah some
people have big TVs and so they're like
1080 sucks
but that's like a small percentage of
people and I don't think anytime soon
you are going to see a massive upgrade
in demand for foreign
but you know a lot of people like phones
are becoming 4K and so I think we need
better compression better data
transmission for the time being it's too
expensive interesting all right let's
see uh where we where we are where we
are
all right Robert Knight says Tim we had
a trans school shooter thwarted in
Colorado Springs today called in by a
sister and law enforcement showed up
they were drunk in room
we did cover that story that's crazy
that's crazy and uh people mentioning uh
fluffer boy says it knows potentially a
copycat yep
Stevie Vivi says don't forget when
Anheuser-Busch merged with a Belgian
company
i-n-b-e-v the list of a b Brands is much
larger than you stated in your other
video thanks for bringing that up it's
AB a b in Bev uh with it's bought and
they have other what do we got here
there's quite a few they own four
companies Sab Miller ambev they own Mill
and inbev yeah they are what was it Sab
Miller you're gonna have to stop
drinking alcohol there's no more I saw
some Here Local only out of the United
States Coca-Cola and Pepsi I think are
wow bottled by these guys I'll keep
naming them as I find them and that's a
trouble with uh
boycotts are you ready to give it up
we got an interesting one here from
Spencer Jones is I was the editor on
those Jack Daniels videos Jack Daniels
had us cut most of the dirty jokes the
drag queens made at least I got paid
interesting huh well yeah that's a thing
a lot of people are saying they're going
to be like yeah Jack Daniels did a drag
thing too drag Paul uh RuPaul's Drag
Race but I'm kind of like I don't care
if adults are doing drag at all like if
if Jack Daniels wants to sponsor him I
don't drink Jack Daniels I don't care
the Dome of anything is that they're
sponsoring someone who's targeting
children and that's where I'm like yo
that's not okay if drag queens want to
do it if Jack Daniels is like hey
there's drag queens and they drink booze
I'm like okay I don't know I'm not gonna
but if you want to boycott Jack Daniels
by all means go do your thing the
Anheuser-Busch thing I think is like
people need to boycott that
because that's just that's not just
about targeting kids that's that's where
we need cultural awareness of the
algorithmic manipulation that our
society is experiencing in the
destruction it will bring
all right where are we at
what do we have Dave Davis says well
there are people in both parties that
want a divorce Marjorie Taylor green
wants a national divorce and if Trump
won in 2020 California wanted a national
divorce this isn't just one side wanting
a divorce which is why I say I think
that's where we're going and it's funny
when people are like oh yeah it's crazy
it'll never happen and I'm like bro the
left and the right are calling for the
Sheep did Marjorie call for it because I
remember last time she was on I think
she said she didn't want it she uh
recently said she that we need a
national divorce Marjorie what about
your kids man well you know I I remember
reading in the New York Times in 2020
how they were gaming out uh disputed
election and uh uh John podesta who's
now working in the Biden white house uh
playing the role of Joe Biden or Hillary
at the time I think it was Joe
uh said that um you know when they
gained it out and there was Trump quote
one and there was an electoral college
dispute the podesta position was we
should have Washington State and
California Oregon threatened to secede
from the union yes unless the electors
were counted the way they wanted to
count so for all of the noise about
January 6 the left was actually War
gaming succession and Civil War
in the 2020 election
and only because the votes went the way
they wanted it to go and we can argue
about that did they pull back on their
on their plans for violence Street
demonstrations and potential secession
all right kid funky fry says what Obama
did wasn't a war crime it was a capital
crime under 9-141.00
the son of an FBI informant you know we
had gotten documents on Anwar alawaki
his father who was the first American
ever assassinated by a U.S president WoW
known and Anwar alawaki was actually
working as a source for the government
at the time we had the FBI document
saying well we followed him in the you
know literally you know followed subject
he got on the Metro we brought all we
broke off contact after he went into the
Pentagon
really and so Obama you know a few years
later he's across you know he was the
leading internet Jihadi and Obama killed
him whether Obama knew at the time that
he was actually a source for a good
period of time for the United States
government I don't know or maybe he was
cleaning up some loose ends yeah well
yep
all right Brandon West says the state is
a mafia pretending to be a human rights
organization
yep all right hello billery Clinton says
if they're going to go after the bidens
then Hunter first and then everyone will
finally see how incompetent Joe is if
you can't father Juan how are you
supposed to Father a nation
I mean just lock them all up indict them
all
that's about it Obama Hillary bill
yep I mean the new rules are
local prosecutors
can attach state law crimes to Federal
issues
and prosecute National politicians do
you think they will though like what are
the odds here I'd love to see it happen
but like what what are you I wouldn't
bet on it
we got this in the regular chat Holy
Verse I saw this one said Tim should get
Natalie slash Contra points although
I'll be clear I think there's enough
that the state actors could get I mean
state attorneys or District Attorneys
could get the bidens
so uh Holy Verse was saying that we
should get Contra points Contra points
has been invited on several occasions
there you go yeah we invite uh Lefty
people all the time who's Contra points
a uh prominent YouTuber a trans woman
who talks about various political issues
relatively popular fairly moderate in
some respects but Lefty and uh
well come on we've invited politics girl
whose Midas Touch podcaster they
responded with like what's it all what's
what's the deal right here's the plan
ghosted us Jack of The Young Turks
obviously won't do it Hassan won't
do it Kyle Kolinski we like him he's
cool he said he wants to find a time to
come out and do it but it's hard because
he hosts his own show and I'll say that
for for Jack euger and Hassan as
well if they host their own show I'm not
going to cry that they can't stop there
should do mine like that's that's unfair
but they're uh and politics girl and you
know can't you zoom a moon or something
like that dude Studio it just doesn't
work you can't do it you can't have a
conversation with someone over a screen
because you can't see each other's faces
so it becomes this weird thing where
someone just talks and then stops and
pauses and then someone talks and stops
and pauses and it's just really awful I
hate it and there's a lot of people who
are like I don't know you could still do
it's like like even we had Don Junior
calling last week I'm like we got the
Discord set up we can now do Collins but
I don't want to do it on the show it was
great to have Don Jr opon and all of
these issues pertaining to the
indictment and what was going on right
plus his dad is you know the front
runner so I'm like let's hear what he
has to say and then we were able to try
and get some questions and but it's hard
because Don can't see us
so when we're talking well when we're
trying to talk he can't hear us either
so he's talking and then someone tries
to bring up a point and it just is
impossible it becomes a show rather than
a discussion yeah yeah so it's just we
want someone to sit down have a real
conversation with a group of people and
talk about things but I think we're
having the dude from uh surf's TV who is
a smaller YouTuber but he's probably
more prominent on Twitter and then he'll
be here we had Destiny the Omni liberal
on the last week and uh he was in for a
surprise I imagine because when he was
on the show he said the indictment of
Donald Trump must have something bigger
in it if it's going to be 34 counts
they've got to have some some more you
know evidence and they didn't and so I
wonder what his view is now the thing is
they have nothing he should come back
let's hear an update from him well I
think I like Destiny I mean you have to
agree with that more agree with this
world view but like
I felt like we had a real conversation
we don't agree on everything he he
thinks things that are untrue or doesn't
know things that we know and like and
vice versa yeah we start talking about
corporate uh colonialism because he was
like we haven't we haven't taken another
country like Russia Stadium like what's
corporate Colonials and it's unresolved
we need to resolve this Steve
but you know like he said Kyle
Rittenhouse was the clearest cut case of
self-defense has ever seen he may be
liberal but he's not lying when he
watches his videos like oh yeah you're
right you know delusional pardon me you
got to respect people who don't check
their brains at the door when it comes
to politics you know that they're going
to just repeat you know the NPC approach
and that goes on both sides but there's
the issue if someone like Destiny is
getting his news from corporate press
he's likely to believe things that are
untrue however Destiny is more likely to
actually watch the video and that puts
him in I guess he's called right wing
the left I mean did you see this Glenn
green wall to the Washington Post the
other day accused the Trump sons of
posting the picture oh yeah of the
judge's daughter in fact that was so
misleading that he got fact checked on
Twitter
I mean he they posted articles about the
daughter that happened to include a
picture and then they lie completely at
uh and he's supposedly the fact Checker
yeah
well you know that's what they do they
lie about everything so that's that's uh
yeah we'll I'll leave it at that
fact checking is a is a really big
problem in the media essay federali says
it's a sucking chest wound lucasms are
alive and well I don't understand what
that means a sucking chest wound is the
specific term for what it is that's
that's what it's called when you get a
hole in your chest it's called a sucking
chest wound
but that's one of those internet rabbit
holes you'll probably
well now he's talking about Luke
radkowski who's come on the show and say
things that didn't quite make sense but
you kind of understood oh oh yeah yeah
so calling it a lukeism is is to imply
the phrase sucking chest wound is
incorrect when it's actually the correct
terminology yep
Canada a Canadian egg says regarding
stab wounds take a driver's license
credit card or equivalent and place it
over the wound to seal it Source
surviving edged weapons police training
video yeah there you go that sounds
horrifying man
yeah could you could you imagine like
getting stabbed and you're holding a
driver's license on your chest knowing
that if you take it off you will die oh
well that's uh that's one I have a
woofer I've done my wolf for training
that's one of the hardest parts about uh
self or not self-inflicted injuries but
injuries to yourself you can't really
it's really difficult to take care of
yourself and administer first aid to
yourself it's really really difficult
knives are deadly weapons yeah
definitely are yep it's funny when they
the saying of don't bring a knife to a
gunfight it's actually like do you know
anything about combat because yeah right
like depending on the circumstances of
the fight the knife might be worse oh
yeah close so much more distance so much
faster yeah yeah and then people I I
feel like a lot of people uh especially
talking about this they've never gone to
a gun range a shooting range you know
what I mean and like no probably
actually fired a weapon it's like you do
realize that watch a video of these cops
and and the cops are shooting and it's
like you have this tiny piece of of
matter you are trying to hit a person
with and you're far away
compared to literally holding and
controlling the knife and the person as
you're ending them like knives are very
very dangerous be careful so so I'm not
a I'm not a much of a gun guy
um so I've done shooting once really 10
years ago
but you know for those of you who have
used weapons and you know you've used
guns right been trained I mean it's a
knife or an effective personal defense
weapon if you're not comfortable with
guns uh I would probably well it depends
on the circumstances uh probably no in
most respects however and it's because
you don't want to be in an actual
grappling fight with someone so it
requires you to be too close to these
and it creates massive risk to yourself
that being said I want you to imagine it
this way you're standing 15 feet from a
target with a bullseye on it
if you were handed a firearm and told
hit the bullseye go
okay the chances of the average person
doing that slim to none you hand the
same average person a knife and say hit
the bullseye go
they will hit the bullseye 100 of people
go I mean go to the Target and stab it
and right in the bullseye yeah and
they're going to be able to do it but
with a with a gun they'll probably miss
they'll make they'll make simple
mistakes and so a gun is a very powerful
and effective weapon in most
circumstances if you're talking about
home defense you probably don't want a
knife you want something like it's funny
because they're banning the effective
Home Defense weapons like you know I
guess a short-barreled rifle with uh you
know actually people mentioned the
Kel-Tec Sub 2000 which was used by the
the trans Mass shooter is it's nine
millimeter rifle with uh with a brace so
it's stabilizing lower uh small around
nine millimeter lower penetrate no uh or
less over penetration so if you're
worried about you know someone break
into your house and you don't want to
hurt other people you want a weapon like
that I think if someone were to break in
my house I wouldn't want to be using a
knife because it means you're actually
in physical contact with the person
increasing risk to yourself and my guess
is just brandishing you know I know the
left doesn't like to talk about the
effective you use of guns they're often
effective just showing them in terms of
self-defense without having to fire them
sends a lot of people running them essay
federality clarified when you said
earlier we're talking about a sucking
chest when that you set a chest sucking
wound and that's why it was yeah that's
why they super chatted okay there you go
played the link I think it's because I
was calling it a chest wound and then I
was trying to like because most people
don't know what sucking chest wound
means yeah
all right
Lily and may says are you old enough to
remember the movie escape from La a life
imitating art a premonition of the
future
I'm old enough to remember Escape From
New York yeah what is it um
Metal Gear that's where the metal gear
character comes from he lands he lands
on the roof or whatever and then before
that the big movie was controversial uh
was the warrior great movie The Warriors
awesome movie I mean it's a bit cheesy
it's non-stop action The Gangs of New
York in the 70s they're the Warriors is
nuts The Spence Spencer says a bill
introduced in Texas to Outlaw child
genital mutilation male circumcision
circumcision is explicitly Exempted and
more main legal why chop a boy still
good question it shouldn't be allowed
well you know what
if you want to compare circumcision to
gender uh uh mutilation of the nature
we're talking about you can try I don't
think it's going to be persuasive one is
sterilization one is
you know an unnecessary surgery I guess
I don't think they should be doing it
but uh there's a difference between
sterilizing a human being and
you can't experiment on patience that's
that's the distinction there's no basis
to suggest that what they're doing to
trans people who think they're
transgendered is anything other than
crazed experimentation well and you're
prohibited no one can probably you can't
participate it you can't legally
participate in that type of process
I gotta stop you right there you're
completely wrong how am I completely
wrong Scandinavian countries in the UK
have already banned it it's not
experimental it doesn't work at all oh
yeah that's right it doesn't work at all
yeah so to have a stock in the UK shut
down and said this stuff is hurting the
kids and not helping them and how do you
say we're beyond that we know it doesn't
work and they're doing it anyway and
there's no way you can test it to make
sure it will work because they did
though it's the type of procedure that
is unethical to perform well but but
listen listen just inherently they they
you can't
but they did right in Europe they did
these things right tracked the data and
then found it have it had a negative
impact and said we're going to stop
doing this from now on and they've
actually told their counterparts in the
US to stop doing it as well and when
Republicans said look at what these
countries are doing we should stop
democrats for some reason love to come
out and say if the Republicans are for
it we're against it and then started
defending something that has already
been shown by socialists or Democratic
Socialist countries to not be effective
so at this point I would say it's not
even experimental it's it's proven to
have failed right and they're still
pursuing it right right but that's why
though they're so here's the interesting
thing I have for for pointing out to
YouTube multiple states have already
banned this outright
these other countries in Europe have
banned it now many states in the US are
Banning it but for some reason the left
is still adamant they need to be able to
do it and they point to like the
American Academy of Pediatrics and all
these institutions that they say oh no
they say it's the right thing to do our
Public Health authorities have failed us
on so many issues all right let's grab
some more Super chats
all right what is this uh Marcus Carter
says I wrote a book I wanted to share
with you and hope you read reclaiming
Independence discovering the Lost duties
of leadership is available in bookstores
now very cool very cool congratulations
hail Hertz says it's awfuls behind all
of it and of course that stands for
affluent white female liberals
that's what uh it was really funny when
Tucker Carlson brought that up he was
like they called me racist and he's like
why it's white liberal women I'm
complaining about he's like I don't care
about black people the white liberal
women I thought that was really funny
like the left is complaining about white
men and Tucker's complain about white
women yeah I was watching that DJ
Jefferson uh Big Jay oakerson stayed up
last night we're talking about uh he
talks about the only people I've ever
called him racists are just white girls
well and that's why you have a lot of
the uh the homosexual Community oppose
this transgenderism because they see
homosexual boys as being it's Erasure
targeted here yeah these are kids that
don't want or shouldn't have these types
of surgeries
and you know what's going on why and and
of course they're the ones who are
regarding it later so they say
all right miles tatique says y'all
underestimate how much is involved with
printing a run of custom beer cans not
likely a marketing team slipped that by
everyone else Quarter Two reporting
Gonna Be Wild I just want y'all to check
out life Leaf remedies and feel better
today
so no yeah I think what's happening is
Millennials are starting to take over
industry and they are pushing more and
more of this weird ideological stuff and
then you have the opposing faction
people who pay attention to politics who
are just like this is weird and I don't
like it so you have some Millennials
some Gen X some Boomers and they're all
saying whoa this is weird and defensive
and it's causing problems for the
company now
but we'll see Anheuser-Busch as Revenue
I think was like 55 billion dollars so
you know but the left doesn't care I
mean it's not going to stop them oh they
don't care
that's fine with them they they've
gotten what they needed exactly so when
Budweiser gets like they don't they're
not gonna buy Budweiser yeah yeah
who knows what they're drinking
all right Winston Alexander says as a
half Korean half white guy I went from
being a banana to Mellow Yellow to a
person of color to white adjacent what's
next LOL apparently now according to
Dungeons and Dragons just Korean you are
no longer white in any capacity
other than the more we talk about
Budweiser the more
I'm thinking boy I could use a Budweiser
all right Saint miles says Tim make your
own brew and have Joe and Crowder slam a
glass mug after they drink it I wish we
could that is very difficult to do beer
you know we could probably partner with
a actually we were talking about doing
this as a local Brewery and we were like
maybe they could craft a specialty beer
for us you know and then we would we
would sell it or or have it at the
studio or something and they were super
down with it we just we just never got
around to it I think it's mostly because
I don't drink beer
you know it makes you fat and it's
poison so yeah I'm just not not going to
drink it so we never did coffee is good
however you know I like coffee coffee's
fun there's this tribe in Central
America that runs for like 17 hours a
day called the Tara umara and they drink
corn beer that's their diet as long as
you burn it off yeah yeah so it is
alcohol yeah yeah what's how do you make
corn no it's corn beer just ferments I
think right it's like anything else it's
all sugar right yeah I feel like it'd be
difficult to make beer because you don't
drink it like you know what coffees you
like so you consider people this is a
nice coffee you should get it too beer
would be harder for for our gang I guess
kermode bear says drop DND and
Pathfinder there are many great non-woke
options castles and Crusades blades in
the dark cult Divinity lost and the old
world of Darkness settings you don't
need Wizards of the Coast to have fun
castle on the Crusades gone School Ian
you know any of this
uh no no I know Pathfinder and DND I
haven't heard of castles and Crusades we
got to do that um culture War DND show
if we can get some DND players I would
love to that's the challenge the idea
was to do a DND show that has Silly
analogs to the real world to see how
people respond to situations and
understand what like see if they can see
through it so so you'd be running a d
and d game using modern you'd be like
Challenger so a group of you know Orcs
are rampaging through the city center
complaining about uh an orc Warrior who
had been imprisoned and then disappeared
and a young elf was rendering Aid when
he was violently attacked and then fired
his bow and arrow upon the attackers was
fled the scene you know and then they're
like
you know
that couldn't have that could happen in
real life the Goblins that live
underground yeah you know and then and
then and then there you go dude the
sewers would be such a I can't that
can't happen in real life theater crazy
all right
heavy arms guy says I want to run a DND
campaign for the timcast crew with all
the politically incorrect stuff intact
just to stick it to Wizards of the Coast
if we if we do a DND show like it's got
to be on Rumble
I don't think it's none of it's
politically I mean it's insanity if this
isn't even
I never thought of it you could make it
became political but the game itself
isn't inherently political it's just a
tab it's like a layout of data yeah it's
what they're reading into it it's the
the lens through which they view their
own world they're applying yeah yeah
Communists everything's political the
game is human-centric that is important
because that is political the whole game
that you would call a half human half
elf a half elf it means that there's
like some human bias in there and that's
the point of it is we're all humans so
that's why right but but you got to
understand Ian all of the elves who want
to play this game are very upset they're
pissed that's right that's where this is
all coming from the big elf Lobby what
is the marginalized Community or
indigenous community that we're all
supposed to be offended for probably
like the dark elves or like the dark
dwarfs you know the underdark all right
let's grab this one uh right here
we've got this from polite rude guy who
says Tim never read my super chats also
bring Trump on yes I would love to have
Trump on the show no no one's saying no
to that one I think it's funny when
would you go down could you go down
there and interview oh yeah yeah but but
like it's an issue he's like a busy busy
guy running for president and people you
know everyone we've talked to who's
associated with the Trump team or people
like we've had Jason Miller here a
couple times I think they're like you'll
get 20 or 30 minutes and I'm like we'll
take it and then what we'll we'll do is
that we'll have Don Jr or cash Patel
hang out with us while we're talking to
Trump trump can get up and leave and go
do his thing and we'll carry on the show
and it's just an issue of
scheduling and coordinating it is very
difficult that's about it my guess is
he'd commit to 20 minutes but then he'd
stick around and keep I think he
wouldn't leave I think no he'd love this
sort of format yeah with people the
whole chat would be saying we love you
and then Trump would be explaining
everything in great detail we would ask
him questions to elaborate he'd
elaborate in Greater detail and everyone
we've ever had on who's like I can stick
around for maybe an hour and we'll be
like okay that's fine after an hour
they're like well I'm not leaving you
know I'm like this is this is going well
you know I'm getting the dogs right so
uh you know I we we are I I don't I
don't think I should say who but next
week we are going to have the greatest
guest we have ever had I'm very excited
otherwise other than you technically
yeah I am making sure to pull out just
to clarify we were we are pulling out
all the stops to make sure that this
guest receives the utmost comfort and
I'm not going to say who but next week
is gonna be lit we're gonna be in Austin
so we've got uh Monday a really great
guest can be very very fascinating
conversation academically about wokeness
Tuesday is going to be my favorite show
we will probably ever do I'm very very
excited for this it is one of the
greatest human uh people people know who
it's going to be as soon as I say this
it is probably the only politician I
could ever say that I actually like so
it's political oh it's absolutely
political it's the greatest politician
I've I've seen in my lifetime and
everyone already knows that we're in
Texas and who's going to be that's all
I'm going to say so there you go guys
I'm really excited for this it's going
to be one of the most exciting days for
me and I think I'm pretty sure Luke will
be there as well so um I'll leave it at
that so smash the like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
go to timcast.com click join us sign up
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show live on the front page
at about 10 10 pm
maybe we'll talk a bit about what's
going on next week and who's going to be
on the show because it's going to be
amazing we got an amazing lineup next
week in Austin
so uh go to timcast.com watch the
uncensored after show at 10 10 pm follow
the show at timcast IRL on Instagram you
can follow me personally at timcast
basically everywhere Tom do you want to
shout anything out uh go to
judicialwatch.org we're suing everybody
about everything
we got to address the current crisis and
uh we only do it with your support so
you know we got to pay the lawyers so
support Judicial Watch right on
absolutely we're suing everybody about
everything is just an amazing t-shirt I
hope that you guys make that as much
yeah people say are you investigating
this I said we're investigating
everything
if there's something you're worried
about yeah I mean like everybody gets a
lawsuit that's true I'm here clear
brimlow I'm a writer for this cool site
called timcast.com you should go check
it out it's all at timcast news on
Twitter and Instagram you can see my
work work from Cassandra Banks Fairbanks
McDonald's uh you can see stuff from
Chris Bertman I know he's a cult
favorite uh if you want to follow me
personally you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclare.b and you can
follow me on Twitter at HC brimlow
thanks so much hey Ian Crossland if you
want to follow me it's here at Ian cross
on anywhere on the internet I'm standing
solidarity with all the half elves and
Orcs out there I'm with you till the end
my friends Tom if people want to follow
you they follow you on Twitter tomfitten
at Tom fitton thanks for coming man
you're welcome
uh yeah uh I have a lot of work to do
for the next couple days for this Austin
show it's gonna be really fun but uh
yeah you guys will enjoy this guest I
think the chat kind of figured it out
yeah they're saying beta O'Rourke you
got us
Tim's favorite politician of all time
yeah he's awesome but you know I always
I I never officially announced because
who knows I mean maybe next week there's
like sorry we got to cancel so right
right also you have to have the
anticipation it's it's the schedule to
appear maybe they're guessing wrong I
mean they don't they you guys don't know
everything all right uh did you shout
out shout out your oh yeah at
iamsearch.com uh I won't be here
tomorrow Kellen will be taking over for
me and uh we will be driving 22 hours to
Texas in a car it's gonna be great all
right everybody we will see you all at
timcast.com in about 10 minutes thanks
for hanging out cheers